[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 my name is Caleb bendy and is
always on your driver on this journey so
today the topic I wanted to cover is a
little bit about more as always chess
improvement so there are a lot of
different ways to improve at chess but
you know there's certain stigmas around
it something you might have heard is are
something you might think is the best
way to improve it chess is to lock
yourself in a room and do tactics for 24
hours a day and then emerge two months
later a chess genius but it turns out
that's not so much the way it actually
happens and so chess can actually be a
very social game and one of the best
ways to improve even when you're
seriously trading chess is to do it with
your friends and so I wanted to go over
a little bit about my process for that
of working with one of my friends and go
over some games that we played some
training games and see where we made
improvements and how it can actually
help you in your games to improve a
chess so let's take a look here I was
playing my friend sama paja who used to
be my teammate on the U of Illinois
chess team and he's about 2,300 USCF I
believe and he plays the Ben Oni which
is an opening I've struggled with and so
I thought it'd be great to play some
training games with him in the benoni so
let's see what happens
d4 Knight f6 c4 c5 d v e6 Knight c3
he takes C takes D six and so we have a
pretty normal starting position in the
benoni I continued with Knight f3 play
g6 and I played here Bishop g5 and so
this was a new line that I wasn't so
sure how to play just yet I didn't know
all the details this is a line that
actually was recommended to me by Robert
and Gauss key so I figured it's probably
pretty good but it's a great chance to
kind of work out some kinks in your
opening repertoire this is what these
training games can really be good for
Sam will play Bishop g7 I continued with
III so I did note that white probably
shouldn't commit to e4 just yet and give
himself a little bit more
time to get his pieces developed black
simply castled I played Knight to d2 and
this is another idea that I had picked
up on in this opening I could play a
Bishop e2 first but maybe that allows
black the chance to play Bishop g4 and
something I do know about benoni so I'm
not sure if you're familiar one of the
black's biggest problems is his lack of
central space and so what do you want to
do when you have a lack of space do you
know what's one of the biggest things
yeah you want to trade pieces and it so
happens in the Benoni that black has
enough space for about three minor
pieces and so if he manages to trade off
just one it's usually quite beneficial
to his position so I play Knight to d2
here avoiding Bishop g4 Knight to d7
Bishop e2 rook e8 and now I played this
move Knight to c4 so what do you guys
think about this move just in general or
any specific thoughts that might be you
might think are good about it or maybe
wrong with it yeah that's right if it's
a lot of pressure here and this was my
idea in the game I wanted to pressure
the d6 pawn so what do we think black is
gonna respond with to try and defend
this d6 pawn
at Queen c7 or bishop f8 are both
options that defend the pawn yeah or a
knight move and this is actually what my
opponent samel went with and so he
played in the game night to be six so
now how does this make Knight to c4 look
does it still make sense that I put my
night on this forward square yeah I kind
of freed his position a bit so I don't
think Knight c4 was actually such a good
move for example in the game I simply
castled but this allows black to trade
off that one piece that we were talking
about so earlier I played 92 trying to
avoid a trade of the Knights and then I
brought the net to c4 which actually
kind of reoffer it up the trade of
knights and so already it's a lot better
to have this go wrong in a training game
right then in an actual game and so this
is a very important idea that I'm gonna
look at a bit more afterwards and I did
look at I did look at afterwards after
the game with my opponent and that's a
place I have found that I could improve
and so this is really what these
training games are great for you pair up
with somebody who knows more about you
more more than you about a specific
position and maybe you more know more
than them in another position and you
can help each other out and learn a
little bit more but let's just see how
this game continued let's see if black
continue to play accurately so we saw a6
of course preparing the natural break of
b5 for black I played a for trying to
slow it down Bishop f5 so you know like
I said with this Knight out of the way
on d7 black can find natural squares for
his pieces so this one makes its way to
f5 I play rook e1 Queen to a5 so of
course I'm my idea is to try it and get
efore through and black is simply going
to expand on the Queen side I played f3
again preparing a 4 we saw Queen to b4
Queen d2 h6 Bishop h4 Knight to d7 and
so I think all of these moves by both
players have been fine so far but you'll
notice that blacks play has really
gotten a lot more natural over the past
a few turns right he's simply bringing
his pieces to the best squares that are
available to them and meanwhile I'm kind
of disc ordinated right a little bit
lacking in my coordination so we played
Knight to d7 and this is kind of daring
me to play e4 right because it looks
like the bishop is trapped obviously I
can't take it right away due to the pin
but he then played Knight to e5 so
attacking my bishop allowing me the
chance to take his bishop and here I
don't know let's try and calculate and
see what white should play should wait
take this Bishop should white play
something else
yeah so you get a pretty interesting
position there right let's let's try and
calculate through so we have Knight or
pawn takes Bishop Knight takes Bishop
Queen takes rook takes rook takes and
obviously Bishop f8 there might not be
such a great move I don't know if you're
still with me in your head but if Bishop
f8 there would be Bishop e7 so it would
be winning a bishop so you can calculate
in your head and it's quite a narrow
line as what we would say black doesn't
have many options so we can get kind of
close to the end we see takes takes
takes takes takes and King age 7 and
then uh it's stuck with my turn there
and so let's think I can bring my other
rook in the game I could try to bring my
knight in the game I could you know
maybe Reema knew from my bishop but I
have to be careful because there's
always threats of Queen takes b2 now and
so what do you think the evaluation
might be in that final position whether
you want to play something like rook e1
or something like 94 or something else
entirely
don't think what should take so you
don't like that final position that we
were looking at
mm-hm
sure so can I ask why you don't like
that final position for white where we
have the t-rex for the Queen well sure
so I mean the final position could
happen after rook a e1 so we're doubling
the Roxxon on the e-file yeah so black
can take on b2
sure that's fair enough does anybody
else think otherwise well it is actually
a very first line we can almost
guarantee that position after a KDE one
because it's a it's a very narrow line
like I said sure so I mean that is very
Bishop a to moving the bishop would keep
your options open does anybody like the
line after pawn takes Bishop yeah so you
guys are thinking like I was and so I
decided that's Bishop I would rather
have this buy shipping get rid of my
kind of weak Bishop maybe I have some
extra vets of taking on g6 and I would
willingly trade off this Queen for the
two rooks fortunately though Mario was
actually closer to the truth here and
this is what I did in the game and we
can see it didn't turn out so well for
me so here I threw an F takes G six and
this does actually force King takes
because I saw that let's see what did I
see
I thought for some reason that a black
would kind of be getting checkmated here
maybe is simply rack ad e1 and rook to
e7 and ideas like this or maybe Rick e7
immediately but you know there's g5
stuff it's a little complicated but it
did force King takes but then it turns
out after rook to e1 Queen takes B to
simply 94 so these are all kind of the
most natural moves and we probably could
have seen this position in our head if
we thought long enough
so yeah this is what happened in the
game and it simply turns out that my
king is gonna be weaker than blacks King
which is kind of strange to think about
because you know the black King has run
all the way up to g6 but thanks to
blacks kind of strong control of these
dark squares my attack kind of just
fills us out into nothing
meanwhile the knight in the queen and
the bishop can all work together very
well to kind of get out my came so
whites actually simply losing in this
line so before we continue let's take a
quick look at the alternative so let's
look at Bishop a2 and now it's actually
not so clear what black should be doing
maybe just Bishop to d7 would be
simplest and again I don't think black
can really be worse here because he's
traded off one piece and really his
other pieces are still on their ideal
squares right so yeah I mean Queen c2
would be fine
maybe it's something like Bishop g3 also
makes sense indirectly putting pressure
here but at least the game would would
keep going right sometimes it's best
just to keep your options open like this
here well yeah
Oh so yeah Bishop e2
so yet this is a this is a very common
idea in the Benoni actually so you're on
the right track well to g4 would be one
option mm-hmm and maybe we're thinking
about playing f5 and kind of forcing the
issue before you're ready to push a 5 CH
3 it's understandable I'll come back to
let's see I'm gonna give a check
King h1 I guess and then I'll come back
to f6
and this is yet this is actually pretty
interesting there might be e5 here I
honestly haven't calculated that far but
yeah so white has ideas is the point you
know the game keeps going but yeah it it
would probably be a better line than in
the game so let's get back to this
position so that's what we were looking
at was Bishop aide to Bishop d7 and then
you suggested f4 yeah so that's where we
were so yeah this is the position we got
in the game however and after Bishop d4
check and the King moved to h1 and then
that comes into e3 you can kind of see
how you know thanks to this control over
f6 my pieces can never really coordinate
against the king there's like one check
but the King could actually just move
and it would be totally fine and my
rooks are kind of interfered from from
each other by this annoying Knight and
white has simply lost here I've tried
Bishop f2 to defend against the mate
threat then I took on e4 or d5 rather
work g8 and we saw unfortunately the
ends came pretty quickly
so yeah so night takes here and then I
had my one trick where if black moved
out of the way
what would white do
yeah there's there's a funny checkmate
here but of course my opponent noticed
and played a queen - Queen - a one
instead simply cutting off the f6 square
and preventing the mate and then I think
I might have resigned here or at least I
should have so yeah that was that game
and so after the game this is the most
important part you can't just play the
game I was talking with samel and we
look back to what he thought was the
critical point which was this Knight c4
move this is allowing a black you know
all of this play all of this the single
piece trade and then from that the
natural play with the rest of his pieces
so he originally thought after Knight p6
I should play something like night a3 to
try to keep the piece on but then you
know we got to talking and we said well
okay why is white putting the piece on
c4 in the first place and we came up
with a couple of turnips we thought
about maybe a four simply biding your
time maybe with the idea of playing a5
so you could prepare this move and the
play might continue something natural
like a6
you know a5 and just doing this very
quickly and now you know black is going
to have b5 ideas and but white is at
least you know not freeing blacks
position right those bishops gonna be
stuck back here this night might come to
e5 but it might not be able to stay
there forever and the game could could
continue a lot more naturally and then
we said okay well if I'm playing a 4 why
don't I instead just Castle and you know
take things in a more slow direction
it's something like h6 Bishop h4 95 and
we see you know a very normal position
now where neither side is really
committed to anything Black is very
narrowly keeping enough squares for all
those pieces but you can kind of tell
okay maybe has one night too many right
this night kind of just seems in the way
and so this is the improvements that we
we thought about that we made
and then let's see how this changed her
play in the second game so we played the
exact same line so the line kind of
begins at Bishop g5 and okay so yeah
Bishop g7 III we follow the same line up
until the critical point here this
should be two and so last game this is
where I think I played Knight c4 in this
game I chose to Castle we saw 95 so
bringing the knight to the natural
square of course now definitely I
wouldn't want to play Knight c4 and here
instead I played the simple h3 so this
is a lot like the lines we're looking at
in the game right white doesn't commit
to anything just yet and kind of forces
blacks hand to try something because if
black doesn't really get something going
eventually I'm going to actually come
through with this plan right and I can
make plenty of useful moves in the
meantime useful moves that don't commit
to anything so just like rook e1 I could
even play Bishop f1 if I so chose I can
play Queen to c2
I can eventually play e4 and really hold
my cards close to my chest until I want
to play this f4 move and break through
in the center so because of that and
because of this annoying pin as well
black chose to play well first a 6 and a
4 which is a pair of moves that are
often traded off and then h6 forcing my
Bishop back so I came back to h4 of
course I wouldn't want to trade I just
want to keep this pin keep this Knight
kind of locked down maybe I have some
threats of playing this in the future
and so black continued with g5 and so
Bishop g3 so what do you think of blacks
idea here playing age 6 and g5 there are
some benefits and there's some drawbacks
and so let's try to think about what
those might be
so yeah that's one way to put it so he
has more space on the Kings side and the
benefit of that space is it breaks this
pin and it might eventually give his
Bishop some some room here his lights
grade Bishop the downside you said is it
opened his king up another way to put it
is it made weaknesses right so
specifically this f5 Square might end up
being weak as well as this pawn might
become a hook so you guys familiar with
the term of hook so what do I mean by
that I mean eventually if I play a break
like f4 or h4 my pawns have something to
latch on to something to hook on to in
this g5 pawn so if I want to open files
around this King I can do something like
f4 and I will have the option to open
the file by taking this fun and so what
do you think would happen if black
played a nonchalant move like rook to b8
kind of biding his time which should
white play here
so you could try something like f4 but
that's pretty committal I'm more of a
fan of playing useful moves until I'm
sure that the time is right to play at
four so I don't think the time is quite
yet right I think there are still more
useful moves that I can kind of include
yeah if I might be useful move clamping
down on the queenside yeah Brooksie one
might be useful though I might like this
work on a 1 so if b5 ever gets played I
can kind of invade there's one move I
have in mind specifically it's kind of a
preventative move as well so yeah ephors
totally fine as well it's got a similar
idea to the move I was thinking of was
thinking why not Queen to c2 right so of
course the black bishop would love to
come to f5 and so why not play Queen to
c2 to prevent that and maybe with the
future idea of bringing my bishop here
and kind of invading along the light
squares right that's one idea for white
that I was actually familiar with so of
course black because of this chose to
play Bishop f5 immediately not giving
myself the opportunity but now this is
where that other idea came into play so
one drawback of Bishop f5 is you're
putting the bishop on a loose square
right a square where it's not defended
and this gives white some more
opportunities some more advantages to
break through immediately so that's
where this other idea of that 4 comes
into play so I decided to play f4 here
because I thought the time was right due
to this bishop being undefended on along
the F file so I'm going to gain some
time thanks to this nasty bishop so
black chose to play with pawn takes f4
and rook takes up 4 and what do you
think the best square is for this bishop
now where should it move to
probably h7 why do you think that well
sure yet
it can stay along this diagonal but why
h7 specifically instead of something
like g6
or even maybe d3
well sure but it defends more squares on
g6 right mm-hmm so you think h7 or g6
maybe either one yeah
anybody disagree yeah so you could come
to d7 but I think this is the diagonal
that black wants to stay on so there's
actually a big difference between g6 and
h7 so I'll let you guys try and spot it
sure so on g6 the black King would have
you know that left square that that free
square to move to but it's a lot more
important than that actually white has
some very concrete ideas that black
needs to stop
sure
so yeah in a lot of ways g6 is a lot
more natural but the thing is the bishop
has to go to h7 here or else black is
actually simply losing and the reason
for that comes after Bishop g6 Bishop h4
and all of a sudden this annoying pin
that black worked so hard to break out
of is right back right back in the game
and this pin is actually almost
impossible to break out of looking at
the game and so this is why the bishop
should go to h7 so how does that make a
difference in this line what if the
bishop were on h7 here what could we do
yeah that's right so this g6 square was
actually needed for the night so Bishop
h7 Bishop h4 then there would be this
annoying night g6 move and I would be
forced to kind of take right or else I
would lose the piece I could play
something like right to c4 but I mean
that's that's really no different yeah
so white our black might have to try
something like Knight to d7 but it turns
out it's very easy to add attackers hear
something like Queen to f1 something
like Knight to e4 maybe is coming as
well and it's gonna be really really
tough to try to break out of this pen
and so we can see what happened in the
game actually Knight to d7
I played Queen to f1 he took on e3
trying to get some counter play I guess
I simply play Knight to c4 Queen to e7
trying to keep an eye on this pawn and
you know trying to sack the exchange to
kind of free up this position here I
played King to h1 and this move is
actually kind of a big mistake but I
think instead probably something like
Bishop g4 would have made a lot more
sense so I'm I up the one of the last
defenders of this Knight and there's
really nothing black can do here I could
also just take this jerk of course and
this would be very very pleasant for for
white I think probably even winning in
the game though I played King h1 black
took here I captured back and black kind
of missed a chance here so you play
Bishop to e2 which would put an annoying
pin on this night I would have to defend
and maybe black could simply add another
attacker and this would have generated
quite a lot of counter play for black
actually in the game he played Ricky
eight kind of missing this which it's a
10-minute game these mistakes are kind
of going to happen
I played Knight to c3 b5 just kind of
desperately trying to break out now
takes takes Knight takes the knight
comes to age 5 sacrificing the Queen in
exchange for this Knight g3 check
and I go with Bishop takes d6 Knight to
g3 rook to f7 so this move was a big
mistake a lot of these past moves have
kind of just been nonsense because I
think black realized that white should
just be completely winning and he was
trying different things to try to break
out so here almost every move wins for
white probably like rook to f2 might be
the simplest trick to f3 or g4 I played
rook F 7 thinking black would take and I
would take and this would be easily
winning of course I missed 92 check
saving the night and this was what was
played and we saw Bishop takes f7 rook
to e1 and some more kind of random
nonsense moves we're in time pressure by
this point and he eventually lost after
hanging his night on g3 so not the best
finish to the game but this wasn't the
most important part kind of the point of
these training games were to work on
these these openings and try to
understand them a little bit better so
once again after the game I goes both
ways we looked back and tried to find
improvements for black and so up to this
point we thought black had actually
played pretty naturally right
he breaks this pin making some
weaknesses yes but also giving himself
some more space and so Bishop f5 f4
takes takes this is what we decided as I
was describing to you was the kind of
fatal mistake
so after Bishop h7 you know we looked a
little bit deeper and so what do you
think's going on here who would you
rather be in this position
no telling know there's no really wrong
answer because some will Definity
definitively declared that he would
rather be black here and black was doing
fine and I thought that white was
actually probably doing a lot better but
we'll see we'll see the arguments for
both sides well I'm just here a thurr B
would you rather be the player with the
white piece in Syria the black pieces
well yeah really in reality it's it's
kind of close to level for a black why
is that so it seems like blacks pieces
that have kind of found homes right for
the moment maybe this nights gonna be
forced to move eventually but for the
moment they are kind of safe
so yeah White's definitely not without
weaknesses but white does have some good
things going for him right
you can't play Bishop h4 immediately but
these threats aren't really going to go
away
sure I clean up one but yeah so you have
to move this rig first and then you know
you kind of have given up the bishop's
but yeah I mean you could simply play
queen f1 first right and you might
follow up with something like Bishop h4
and now there are legitimate threats
against the the knight
so that's kind of the thing is as White
has these concrete threats against f6
and against the Kings side whereas if
black can manage to hold White has
really given up quite a lot right he
gave up the ability to kick this night
away he gave up kind of this weakness
saw on the e pod and so it's just going
to be matter if kind of black and
weather this storm and so we looked at
quite a few lines here actually yes so
Knight to g6 is what we settled on black
tried a variety of other things though
samel had quite a few ideas here after
Queen to b6 there's actually a really
crazy line I wanted to show it looks
like it's hanging the two pieces for the
rook black we can continue with taking
and now actually the best move here is
not to save the rook not to try to
defend the knight not to bring the rook
over to the Kings side actually it's
Bishop h5 which is kind of a crazy idea
giving up the rope with check the King
moves to h2 and now if you take this
Knight there's Bishop h7 and so if the
King we're to move away there is
checkmate so you actually have to take
this piece and after Queen takes c3
white ends up with a queen for two rooks
in a balance we've seen before
but here I think it would definitely
actually favor white thanks to how
exposed blacks King is and how safe my
king is so yeah that would be a really
crazy line that the game could have gone
down but we decided 96 was probably the
best line for black
and the most reasonable actually in a
practical game so simply rook to f3 look
just best for white defending this pawn
keeping some pressure the Black Knight
might come back to e5 and now we come
back to f2 avoiding the repetition
Knight F to d7 so black does actually
want to get this Knight out of danger
kind of now we're looking at bringing
more pieces into V attack and you can
kind of see the flow of the game right
so why it's gonna put all those pieces
over here and attack blacks King and
black is gonna try to defend to the best
of his ability and so this is why I kind
of preferred the white pieces I like to
be more the attacker in these situations
and then the defender but you know it's
not to say black is is worse here
although if you look at the specifics
maybe he is but if black can hold on
then black should have a very
comfortable game so yeah we were
analyzing with a computer yeah it's
first I would recommend going over it
without a computer looking at the
practical choices and then it's helpful
to see the the true the truth in the
matter which the computer can can
sometimes give not always but sometimes
c4 is a very natural move for black to
try trying to get this night into d3 we
saw so many workout for Knight to g6 and
the same idea but in this case the white
bishop can no take it and we looked at
Bishop takes but sighted maybe Bishop h4
was just winning after something like
Queen to e5 something like Knight to f6
in some manner
I looked actually quiet quite nice for
for white so that's how we came up with
a bishop here so one Bishop h4 that
would be g5 and yeah this is just kind
of a crazy position we decided on we
didn't go too much further than this
because it would be a little bit silly
to and not so much productive because
the point of these training games were
to work in the openings but so
definitely interesting stuff so you can
kind of see how in two short 10-minute
games both players made pretty
significant improvements to their
repertoire
right
as for me I learned a lot about when
it's correct to play Knight c4 and how
usually Knight c4 isn't going to be the
best choice when black can simply
respond by offering a trade
and as for samel I think he learned
quite a bit about this f4 break and what
the specifics of it when it's good for
white when it's not good for white and
what to do and to be careful about this
pen so two short games and actually
quite a bit learned so I think this is a
really great way to work on your
openings especially is doing these
training games with with a friend now
with that in mind I did give some of the
white pieces a couple times and we
played at Cairo con so let's take a look
at the Cairo games and how they went I'm
blowing by all these moves because they
are well-known theory so this is just
the classical Carroll con usually white
play is Queen to d5 and so the idea of
this is black doesn't want to get
checked it doesn't want to get check
mated and white wants to checkmate black
so very often black will bring this
Queen to d5 and offer a trade of Queens
and go in for an endgame where maybe
this H pawn is a little bit weak this D
pawn might end up being a little bit
weak and blacks probably not getting
checkmated if he trades Queens which is
how the very natural Bishop e3 comes to
light so this is a pretty common line
but should be through I would say is the
first move of the line against the the
classical Cairo and the idea is simply
you're putting a bishop in the way so
the Queen on the Queen on e4 won't
actually be able to trade and so I knew
that black actually had a few options
here
I know Queen to b5 was maybe the main
one but I had looked at that line before
and I didn't really like it so much
I knew b5 was another choice and I kind
of just assumed black could do something
natural like arcade to d8 as well in
this game I decided to play b5 if you're
a longtime fan you might recognize this
game from my match against Jonathan
trance if not don't worry about it don't
check it out because I lost Sun Knight
to e5 a very natural move
v5 kind of weakens this Square a little
bit 95 takes advantage of that and it
also threatens us to start pushing these
pawns up the board I played the same
move I did against Jonathan I played b4
we saw g4 and in response I responded
with 94 and then samel deviated from the
game I had against Jonathan so after
Rick to g1 what do we think is going on
here
so what are white's ideas first of all
they're a little bit easier to see yeah
so he's just very naturally going to
push this pawn to g5 and give checkmate
if I don't do something about it so yeah
his real ideas f3 cuz if you played a
let's say g5 right away maybe I could
get away with taking it with I don't
perhaps with with the bishop I'm gonna
say and yeah or maybe with the night so
it would be useful for for white to
actually push the night away and then go
ahead and continue with g5 and this
would be quite strong for white so in
the game I decided I had to do something
pretty immediate or else I would risk
being checkmated so I decided to try to
break with c5 right away it's all Mele
just continued with f3 and so I decided
you know C takes d4 here was really my
only chance
white responds with Bishop takes d4 it
wouldn't make too much sense to trade
off these pieces simply because it makes
my defensive task a little bit easier
now this pawn can never come to f4 and I
can kind of keep control over g5 sure so
Queen a5 a little bit better
yeah so you can take it but the night is
hanging yeah so f3 is actually the best
move
so after C takes d4 of course white
doesn't take the night key instead takes
the pawn defending his own Knight
forcing my knight to move away I chose
this square but unfortunately this
fall's to a tactic after Bishop takes
Queen takes in 97 and so this is kind of
where the game lost interest
so I mean white converted very well here
I simply pushed his pawns and checkmated
me pretty horribly a pretty mean of him
to give checkmate like this but you know
that part of the game wasn't as
important right the important part was
the opening in the early middle game the
strategy from both players and so once
again we looked at this line afterwards
which is the what where the real
improvement comes so I played b5 you
play 95 and it turns out we think this
b4 move probably wasn't quite the best
simply due to you know White's pawns
coming down the board so quickly and 94
actually is completely busted because of
this work virtue one move and there's
really nothing black can do here to stop
the pawns from coming down so we went
back here and after Knight to D 95 we
looked at a few different options for
black and so what do you think some
options might be
besides this b4 idea to try to slow down
White's plans
Bishop d6 I thought you said yeah so
what's the idea here
so you want to get rid of the knight but
there's an important line you have to
look out for which is f4 so we're gonna
play after f4
okay so Knight to e4 maybe what happens
one I just kind of want to play this
anyways what happens if Brooke aged
three though preparing g4
is that better than g1
so a tricky one I don't know I thought
maybe the knight could plant on after 30
and reroute sorry I just wanted to
defend the g3 square
I mean okay you could play something
like this but the the fact is you know
these pawns are really coming down the
board great f6 not a very pretty move
but oh yeah a lot of weaknesses here
even Knight to g6 maybe but okay Knight
2 D 3 is a little bit easier to
calculate and yeah I mean these moves
are coming anyways so you need something
more direct to stop stop White's ideas
you're on the right track though the
subform move gives up control over a
couple key squares and so how do we want
to use those squares
that's exactly what I was thinking so
the Queen could come to e4 and then
what's the follow-up here what if you
know white simply defends the the bishop
there you go
okay maybe Ricki one wasn't the best
example move you're a mission before
we'd be possible I'm not sure that would
make the most sense so what if something
like Queen f2 will say yeah 95 this is
the this is the big idea is we can kind
of force this Bishop back and get our
pieces into pretty good positions here
with that in minds
I'm trying to think how play might
continue here it's a little tough
yeah I'm not so sure for one you could
actually take this night now you can can
you could consider doing something like
this and playing maybe Queen to b4 and
all of a sudden you have a lot of
counter play right like this is
threatens this is threatened and
basically the idea is you get your
pieces on very good squares and white
has to waste a lot of time other than
that I'm not sure what else white might
try it of course this line would be even
easier you're just going to trade the
night for the bishop and then if you
ever need to you can actually go ahead
and turn this Bishop for this night as
well and then it's pretty hard to
checkmate black so that's kind of the
problem with f4 here which is the most
natural move but it gives up this efore
square and queen e4 is actually quite
good for for black so we started looking
at other things right and maybe
something like Knight to d3 it could be
the best move but then we find out after
something like a 5 very natural black
just continues its attack maybe this
isn't so so good for white either right
his attack is coming a lot slower in
facts let's see I think I analyze some
other lines here as well okay maybe just
a 5 and you can try something like g4
but let's see here what's going on
yeah maybe Queenie for but there is f3
this is usually the problem well here
there's there's also f3 so yeah I don't
know something like a 5 and you know the
attack might continue on both sides you
could probably consider playing a 94
here it's a little bit better you still
have to play something like this and
let's see let's see there's a lot going
on here it's it's tough to kind of
calculate on the fly but it would be
certainly be a bit more interesting
other ones we looked at were Bishop c1
but maybe it's fine to just play c5 here
taking advantage of this loose Knight
now and so yeah this was kind of being
proven that we made for black possibly
and an improvement for for white as well
instead of F for something like Knight
to d3 and so kind of a lot was learned
from there right we played one 10 minute
game analyzed it afterwards and we
learned that you know this Bishop d6
idea is very important it's very
important to learn how to kick this
Knight immediately it's very important
for white not to give up this efore
square quite so quickly especially when
Queen e4 as possible because it allows
black to get his pieces on the very
natural squares so let's see how we
implemented those ideas in game 2 here
so we played the same line
and we got to the same position so
Bishop III and so I decided to take
those ideas that we learned from the
previous game and try to apply them here
and so I just played a natural move rook
a to d8 and I wanted to see if I could
apply these ideas in a slightly
different position black or white played
the same way with 95 and I tried the
same idea with Bishop to d6 and here
actually white kind of fell in for the
for the same track but this f4 move so
of course I tried Queeny for Ricky one
simply Knight to d5 Bishop c1 and we
went in for a queen trade I took on any
five white also captured on you five of
course that would be a mistake to play
the natural D take C due to this tactic
right
the discovery so because of that we
played rook take C and now what do you
think about this endgame who's doing
better here
sure so the night has a good outpost
the bishop
yes okay black has a good night so
that's why you're saying black might be
better any other thoughts so yeah that's
the big thing is the black pawns are all
kind of close to home with a lot of
different options to kind of defend
themselves whereas these three pawns in
particular are all pretty far advanced
and it's why it's actually gonna have a
tough time defending all of them and so
for that reason I would definitely say
black is doing quite well here well it
depends on what you mean by activity the
stroke is centrally placed but was it
really accomplishing right it's
attacking me six in d5 which are both
always going to be well defended and
perhaps it's even going to be vulnerable
to some Knight g4 move later on so I
simply play Knight to f6 here and after
rook 2 D 3
I had the simple idea of doubling along
the D file first I inserted I think B 6
keeping the white rook out of a 5 and we
can see now white felt the need to go
for c4 trying to break through in the
center which would get rid of one of his
weaknesses which is why he's trying to
break through but black plays very
simply and just threatens to double and
in white felt the need to actually play
you're up to e1 here and so what do you
think black should do there's a couple
options
see this pawn is simply hanging right so
that's what I played in the game i I
just took the pawn but white actually
came up with some ideas after that so
there's a better move here for black
better than just taking yeah that's
exactly right so you double the rooks
force wait to make some concession to
defend yeah he wasted the tempo we got
our rook in the game we can even play
something like c5 here if we really want
to or we could just take immediately now
instead though I did capture this pawn
but this ran into some threats after
something like g4 we saw Knight to f6
and g5 the bishop defended it yeah so
now where do we want to put our knight
limited options actually h5 I mean yeah
so this would be the best Square why is
that
well sure on e8 though you're looking to
come come around right so that's the
main thing is on h5 the knight can
sufficiently block the file to keep the
King safe and so black would actually
still be doing well after Knight h5 not
as well as a peon started the circ d8
move but still pretty well in the game I
played night to e8 which of course now
white is actually generating some some
pretty serious threats
I tried g6 to give my my King some space
you played the other Rick over to h1
threatening actually checkmate so I kind
of played f5 out of necessity this was
really my only choice to kind of save my
king so he captured it I captured with
my night and after check King g7 so
somehow none of my pieces are hanging
just yet you might see this Bishop h6
move but thankfully the Sturken h8 would
then be hanging and so I would barely
survive here and in most lines it turns
out I'm actually barely surviving so I
think black is ok here but definitely
not any better sorry was that yeah so
you can do this but now the point is I
can come up in mine I can kind of block
I think this is actually probably very
good for white though if you play a
simple Bishop f4 I think this is
actually causing a lot of sorrow was
that
that's what he did in the game but this
would be this would be better because
you're simply bringing this Bishop into
e5 and then this Knight on g7 isn't
going to feel very safe black is maybe
actually lost here but you know again
it's a 10-minute game we spent most of
our time in the early middle game part
so that's what we were trying to improve
and so mistakes made on both sides
definitely so we saw Bishop g5 here and
after some shuffling I managed to play
Knight of fate and kind of consolidate
and hear my opponent actually ran out of
time but black should probably win this
endgame although definitely not easily
so what did we learn in this game let's
let's go back so this game was mostly
about this f4 move right this was the
big mistake for white so let's try and
find something better for white here so
this this is how I can kind of go in
these games is the person who loses
tries to find out why they were worse
out of the opening or out of the middle
game and then make an improvement so in
this game it was my opponent who was a
little bit worse
so f4 definitely not the idea what can y
do instead
so f3 would be a kind of preventative
move but it turns out white doesn't
actually need to play f3 right as long
as he has the pawn on f2 let's just
waste a tempo if I ever play Queen e4
he'll always have f3 in response right
so there's no kind of need to spend a
spend a tempo doing this
yeah g4 would be interesting but you do
have to be careful I think I can just
take this Knight
yeah I was just thinking just
okay I mean you have to understand
though this is a upon sacrifice and so
you have to be very very careful if
you're going to play this way I think
actually white does have to deal with
this problem of this night somehow so
what are his choices to stop black from
winning this pawn 94 would be
interesting so you're attacking this
bishop let's see black probably has a
lot of options here
maybe 94 might be a good move maybe not
though
okay let's say Bishop c7 just simple
which you solved the problem of the
night yeah so you can continue with your
normal ideas here perhaps though this
isn't the best square for the night
you're on the right track
I think Knight to d3 would be a better
version of this Bishop c7 I don't think
is quite so accurate I don't know if
Black has to spend that tempo but yeah
so I think 99 to d3 would be a better
version of this maybe Knight c4 is
actually also good though
against 93 I was thinking black could
probably try something like rook e8
maybe something similar would happen
against Knight to c4 and let's see do
you want to continue a g4 still all
right let's take a look here
so maybe 94
so you got to be careful of this fork
right so if you do want to kick the
night you have to play something like
grouchy one first work age three is
that's totally playable as well and
let's see what can I do
yeah sure maybe I can play a Bishop e7
no kind of for treating and okay it's a
game I can also probably play c5 here
and this is the the big break that black
really wants to get through and these
lines that actually all look very
similar to Knight to t3 and so something
like g4 and blacks ideas he wants to
break in the center to kind of counter
all of White's play
so yeah Knight c4 definitely playable
and so yeah it might go something like
this where white is actually really
breaking through but black has enough
counter play thanks to the open central
files against the white pieces so we can
see takes maybe h6 and Bishop d4 and
black would be doing quite well here so
white would probably have to play a bit
better maybe let's see what else can
white do here
I've kind of forgotten something like
Queen to d2 just simply playing
naturally although there's 94 maybe yeah
I'm not so sure
so maybe actually let's see so okay
that's right so I decided we decided
that maybe 93 94 aren't the best because
black does get this counter play in the
center but there's actually a very very
strong move for white here that we
haven't mentioned yet it's kind of
unnatural
yes c4 is the move and so why is this so
good let's take a look well first of all
what happens if the black Queen comes to
a5 so it's kind of out of the game but I
can always kind of jump back in there's
some real problems here though so the
problem is f4 right so we no longer have
this Queen d5 idea against f4 so why can
simply solidify this night and continue
very quickly on the Kings side with that
in minds the most natural move seems
like check right so we can check this
king the King will simply run away
though and now the problem is what do we
do next right maybe you won't take the
knight but here is where unfortunately
White's trick lies so white has a a good
move in response to this line
oh yeah if you're in the Knights please
go ahead and and start that Rondo okay
all right so okay really quickly white
can play f3 here forcing this Queen back
and then taking this Bishop so yet this
line would actually be lost for for
black and so because of that you know we
found an improvement for white we also
found an improvement for black here
turns out instead of Bishop d6 something
like Knight to d7 is a lot better and
the reason is we have this extra square
for the Queen and we can keep these
threats against the night and keep this
g5 square under control so any questions
about what we cover today or this game
specifically alright so in summary what
this lecture was kind of about is it was
to show you kind of the method of which
you can play training games against
somebody it's a very fun way to improve
and it can be very helpful especially
with your opening repertoire and that
early middle game stage where you're
trying to find out your plan and where
your pieces go so hopefully you learned
a little bit about the Benoni and a
little bit about the care today but it's
supposed to be a method you can kind of
take home and employ yourself to
personalize to to yourself to kind of
work it's a great way to train it's a
great way to get better and with that in
mind that's gonna be all for me tonight
so thank you guys for joining me here
thank you guys for watching on YouTube
and I'll see you next week on the road
to 2000s
you